un déplore le le la perte de cette
police de proximité alors si les
gouvernements successifs veulent pas la
remettre pour pas avoir le sentiment de
se dégger changeons le nom mais en fait
on a besoin d'une police au contact des
quartiers et puis il y a un non dit je
profite que j'ai un peu de temps vous
voyez mais parce que sur BFM vous pouvez
pas
le trafic de stupéfiant
empêche une police de proximité empêche
même aux pompiers d'intervenir des fois
parce que vous avez des personnes qui
tiennent le four comme on dit à quand la
légalisation quand est-ce qu'on mesure
enfin que non seulement ça pose des
problèmes de sécurité je pense que j'ai
pas besoin de développer mais surtout le
santé publique donc l'égalisation du
cannabis l'égalisation du cannabis on a
une des politiques les plus répressives
ou en tout cas mesureront qu'un débat
vous voyez je veux pas arriver avec des
solutions toutes faites et ça ne serait
de toute manière qu'une partie de la
solution mais quand est-ce qu'on peut
poser sérieusement le débat d'une
politique pénale la plus répressive en
Europe parmi les plus répressives et du
taux d'addiction chez lumineux le plus
élevé vous voyez si vous la légalisation
du cannabis ça peut être une solution
pour rétablir un calme dans les
banlieues certainement pas la seule
certainement pas la seule mais il
n'empêche que ça peut mettre fin à des
trafics qui sont quand même installés
dans des cités ou les policiers c'est la
santé publique le cannabis est dangereux
pour les adolescents en particulier
le cerveau se développe il y a un
phénomène d'addiction qui est
indubitable
il se trouve que la prohibition est un
échec voilà et par ailleurs ça plein
d'effets négatifs corollaire sur la
sécurité et même sur la surpopulation
carcérale
je relisais il y a pas longtemps on
l'appelle de Grigny et c'est mer qui de
banlieue qui il y a quelques années
disait au secours on nous enlève les
emplois aidés alors il y a eu tout un
sujet sur les emplois aidés un sujet
idéologique mais Jean-Luc Borlo les
appelle les emplois aidants vous voyez
c'était du soutien scolaire c'était un
appui à la mairie ou aux associations ça
fait cinq six ans qu'ils ont disparu et
ce qu'on n'est pas en train d'en payer
le prix avec la situation actuelle
[Musique]